allocution du président de la fédération
aussi vous l'admirent poutine mesdames
messieurs chers invités venus de
l'étranger
j'ai l'honneur de vous saluer pour la
9ème conférence de moscou sur la
sécurité internationale
votre rencontre représentative traitera
des questions majeures de l'ordre du
jour politique et militaire de leurs
résultats de la recherche de réponses
communes efficace aux défis du moment
dépend la consolidation de la sécurité
sur notre planète le développement
durable de notre civilisation
malheureusement les perturbations dans
les processus géopolitique ne font que
croître malgré certains signaux positifs
distincts on constate la poursuite de la
dégradation du droit international on
constate des tentatives d'utiliser la
force pour imposer ses intérêts
renforcer sa sécurité aux dépens de
celle des autres
les conflits armés régionaux suscite la
préoccupation les risques de
prolifération des armes de destruction
massive
l'activité des groupes criminels
internationaux des narco trafic et de la
cyber criminalité le terrorisme
international constitue toujours une
menace particulière
je répète l'ampleur et le caractère
planétaire des problèmes mentionnés
impose pour tous les pays d'unir leurs
efforts et ce travail collectif doit
évidemment s'appuyer sur le droit
international les objectifs et les
principes de la charte de l'onu
depuis sa fondation l'onu est et demeure
la base du système des relations
internationales
la mission principale de cette
organisation reconnue et qui bénéficie
d'une autorité et d'éviter un conflit
mondial une nouvelle guerre mondiale
c'est sous son égide que doivent être
élaborées les nouvelles règles du jeu
tout autre chemin mène au chaos et à
l'imprévisibilité hier nous avons
célébré une date tragique
les 80 ans de l'agression de l'allemagne
nazie contre notre pays pour nous les
leçons de la seconde guerre mondiale
revel tu revêtent une valeur
particulière et nous ferons tout pour
garantir la paix la sécurité pour le
peuple de russie perfectionner notre
armée est aussi bien sûr recourir à la
diplomatie
avoir un dialogue constructif avec tous
les partenaires intéressés
nous n'imposons jamais notre volonté aux
autres pays nous sommes prêts à utiliser
les méthodes diplomatique sur un pied
d'égalité pour travailler à la
résolution des problèmes mondiaux et
régionaux étendre une coopération
constructive avec tous les pays nous
développons notre potentiel militaire
sur l'eau le principe de la suffisance
raisonnable nous ne cherchons pas une
supériorité militaire unilatérale
déterminante et un déséquilibre des
forces en autres sauf entre nos faveurs
surtout dans un domaine aussi sensible
que la stabilité stratégique mais nous
ne permettrons à personne de faire
pencher la balance de son côté
nos efforts sont orientés vers la
diminution des risques la prévisibilité
et la résolution des divergences par le
dialogue et la conclusion d'accords
notamment en matière de contrôle des
armements
à cet égard je vous rappelle que la
russie a avancé des propositions visant
à élaborer un nouvel équilibre de
sécurité il doit prendre en compte tous
les facteurs influençant la stabilité
stratégique et dans leurs interactions
nous sommes convaincus que la volonté
politique et la disposition à trouver
des compromis peuvent donner des
résultats positifs
la preuve en est la prolongation par les
etats-unis la russie du traité sur la
réduction des armements offensifs
stratégiques jusqu'à 2026 bien entendu
nous ne pouvons pas rester indifférents
à l'augmentation du potentiel et des
infrastructures de l'otan à proximité
des frontières de la russie
surtout que l'otan refusent nous
proposition de désescalade et de
réduction des risques d'incidents a
prévu nous espérons que le bon sens et
le souhait de mener avec nous des
relations constructives domineront
finalement un autre aspect de la
stabilité mondiale et le règlement des
conflits régionaux la russie jouera un
rôle important
grâce à notre aide militaire nous avons
réussi à libérer des terroristes
internationaux
une grande partie du territoire syrien a
évité l'effondrement de l'état syrien et
le travail effectué dans le cadre du
format astana avec la turquie et l'iran
a permis de lancer le processus de
règlement syrien sous l'égide de l'onu
grâce aussi à l'intervention de la
russie il a été mis fin au conflit dans
le haut karabakh
les soldats de la paix de russie
garantissent la paix la sécurité dans la
région
ils font beaucoup pour améliorer la
situation humanitaire procéder à des
opérations de déminage et restaurer les
infrastructures sociales la russie
n'oublie jamais la responsabilité
qu'elle assume vis-à-vis de la sécurité
de la prospérité des pays voisins avec
lesquels nous avons des liens
historiques culturels et humains nous
sommes déterminés à continuer à
contribuer à la résolution des conflits
régionaux avant forcer la paix la
stabilité sur le continent que nous
avons en commun en conclusion je tiens
vous souhaitez des travaux fructueux et
tout le meilleur je suis convaincu que
les participants à la conférence auront
des discussions intéressantes et que les
propositions et les initiatives qui en
découleront serviront au renforcement de
la sécurité internationale et de la
stabilité
merci pour votre attention allocution du
secrétaire général de l'onu antonio
guterres s je remercie le ministre de la
défense se gâche au bout de m'avoir
invité à participer à cette conférence
la 9e conférence de moscou sur la
sécurité c'est la possibilité pour nous
de discuter des points les plus
importantes de l'ordre du jour la russie
étant un des pays fondateurs de l'onu
est membre permanent du conseil de
sécurité s'est toujours appuyé sur la
discussion multilatérale
la pandémie de covile 19 et les menaces
qui ont été entraînés provoqué par cette
pandémie nous ont permis de mieux
comprendre l'importance de la
multipolarité tout cela nous permet de
développer le partenariat entre les pays
dans le cadre de l'onu et des autres
organisations internes au sein des ces
partenariats
peuvent permettre de résoudre
efficacement les questions d'armement de
prolifération des armements de
cybercriminalité de désinformation je
remercie la fédération de russie pour
son implication et sa contribution à la
stabilité est aussi dans la lutte contre
la pandémie et je vous souhaite de
fructueux travaux lors de cette
conférence
je vous remercie mais serge de solides
assure du ministre de la défense de la
fédération de russie général d'armée
sergei couche catholique
choïgou
mesdames et messieurs aujourd'hui nous
commençons les travaux de cette 9e
conférence de moscou consacrée aux
questions de sécurité internationale la
participation à ce forum délégation de
son pays et de notre organisation était
de six organisations attendait ça veut
dire que nous avons sur ce passé l'étape
d'isolement du à la pandémie de korma
virus ceux-ci se donnerait environ sur
et avis aux mystères de défense qui dans
le monde entier en ta porte à leur
secours à la population et a cumulé une
vaste expérience très précieuse qui nous
permet d'envisager l'avenir avec
optimisme se tanner célébrons une date
triste dans l'histoire de notre pays le
22 juin 1941 il y à 88 ans commencez la
grande guerre pour la patrie qui a duré
1418 jour et nuit pendant ce temps
l'union soviétique a perdu plus de 27
millions de vie militaire et civil
compris nous gardons la mémoire de tous
les morts
indépendamment de leur appartenance
ethnique
nous sommes reconnaissants aux
gouvernements des pays où l'on cultive
la mémoire des soldats soviétiques
tombés sur les champs de sur le champ
d'honneur il faut que les jeunes sachent
et respecte l'histoire commune et
et réponse à toutes les tentatives pour
et rusé et de faire ressurgir le nazisme
je vous propose de la mémoire de tous
les morts de la seconde guerre mondiale
par une minute de silence
merci mesdames et messieurs cette
conférence de moscou qui par tradition
offre la possibilité d'un dialogue
ouvert sur les problèmes les plus
brûlants de la sécurité internationale
je tiens à noter que les relations inter
étatiques se développe et évolue sans
cesse donc ce qui fait surgir des
priorités dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme dans le contexte d'un monde
multipolaire aujourd'hui les
propriétaires via les nouvelles
tendances dans la formation d'une
coalition globale qui a divisé
le monde un ami et ennemi le rôle des
états souvent augmente pour assurer la
sécurité de leurs fils et leurs citoyens
la part des miens revirement serait que
les frontières nationales et gardent
leur importance parce que les percements
au niveau national on peut organiser la
quarantaine et apporter le
le secours à la population plus la
pression agressive économique qu'aux
moyens pour contraindre à des
changements dans la politique d'état
souverain on utilise ci devient de
censure économique et financière qui
s'ajoutent aux à la pression de force on
provoque des incidents militaires et des
coop à deux des informations de la
population
leurs méthodes et procédés de cette
ressource deviennent universelles
produit mass universelles sont utilisés
dans toutes les parties du monde
ces problèmes se posent avec une acuité
particulière en asie du sud-est lépi son
contrat vaut de faire un choix
alors impose la création de structures
analogues à l'hôtel comme en euros on y
crée des groupements avancé dehors d'
alerte élevé on y crée des groupes de ce
chrono de porte-avions et d'aviation aux
exercices
en mer se font à participent aussi des
pays de l'alliance de l'automne c'est
que moi tu le donnes le risque
d'incident pendant toutes ces activités
para militaire en europe à naulleau
depuis la guerre froide
on a créé des systèmes de règles s'il ya
des accords bilatéraux qui interviennent
pour prévenir des incidents pendant
l'action de l'aviation et de la marine
dans alors que dans la zee le pacifique
haussez ce dispositif d'absa ces
situations c'est grave par des litiges
territoriaux il ya des zones de contrôle
de l'espace rien prioritaire nous
estimons que les réseaux sécurité de
l'activité militaire il faut le rester
sur le mécanisme qui exclut les
incidents militaires méritent notre
discussion dans des comptes forums
multilatéraux entre les ministères de
défense des pays d'asie-pacifique
d'un autre côté ne se prête à partager
notre expérience dans la règlement de
ces questions une autre tendance de ces
dernières années c'est un déploiement
massif des m2 anti missiles alors
collusion avec les expériences montrent
le rôle déstabilisateur du cep de
défense antimissile dans la région
d'asie-pacifique nos appréciations se
confirme en europe où la desserte
régionale constitue un des éléments pour
l'autre contre un pour contenir la
russie par l'otan a donc pu céder une
défense antimissile contre la russie et
la chine ne supporte plus les critiques
la situation se complique c'est qu'après
le retrait de des états unis eau de la
corse terre de portée intermédiaire donc
tous les efforts pour le déploiement de
ces missiles aussi en asie de point de
vue du point de vue militaire au la
composante ici de choker ne fera pas qui
peut changer la faire pencher la balance
dans cette région et dans le monde
entier et la décision pour placer des
missiles de portée intermédiaire si elle
est prise
cette situation sera dangereuse aussi
pour les régions de l'est de la
fédération de russie la menace des
systèmes de défense antimissile abm a
c'est aussi la présence de missiles de
frappe lors la médiévale à
l'amélioration de leur performance et de
perfectionnement de leur utilisation
toute décision signifie une nouvelle
étape
il relance la course aux armements ce
qui va freiner le développement des pays
de la région qui est une locomotive de
l'économie mondiale au cours de ces
dernières années la coopération
multilatérale d'épée avec la de la
russie avec les pelles heures ou jours
s'est étendu nous apportons notre
contribution au renforcement du
potentiel militaire de défense de ce
pays en formation de personnel
échanges d'expériences dans le cadre des
conférences entre les ministres de
décider de leurs partenaires en affaires
ces derniers temps d'en améliorer la
coopération avec nos partenaires
stratégiques la chine à la deux le
vietnam le laos myanmar la mongolie non
content et on alors le large tête des
charges avec l'indonésie les philippines
brunei nous allons poursuivre notre
travail dans ce sens le développement de
la situation en afghanistan
merrick une attention soutenue des pays
limitrophes et aussi des organisations
internationales
force nous est de reconnaître qu'en 20
ans de ses joues de groupements
importants de l'alliance occidentale
cette dernière n'a pas su trouver des
résultats positifs pour créer des
structures stables de gestion nationale
après le retrait de l'otan on pourrait
s'attendre au renouveau de la guerre
civile en afghanistan avec toutes les
conséquences que cela suppose avec
l'aggravation des conditions de vie de
la population des migrations de masse la
propre sur de l'extrémisme sur les états
voisins aux états voisins dans un stade
voisin au pad à eau
l'effort solitaire le comté joe la
russie a toujours plu à consolider les
efforts une politique concertée en
afghanistan les russophobie au sein de
l'alliance atlantique l'a emporté sur
l'autisme qu'aujourd'hui pour rectifier
la situation il faudrait des mesures
d'urgence qu'il faudra actionner les
mécanismes de chat gay de l'aco de
l'organisation de la coopération de
shanghai avec tous les pays limitrophes
y compris le pakistan et l'iran
sa comparse avec islamabad et teyran on
pourra pas défaire le noeud afghan dans
le cadre de l'organisation du traité de
sécurité collective des mesures seront
prises pour accroître le potentiel de
défense de cette organisation dans un
contexte nouveau
nous sommes ouverts au dialogue avec nos
partenaires occidentaux l'afrique le
proche orient qui vivent à les
conséquences des révolutions colorées
qui ont été imposées de l'extérieur par
une explosion démographique ce sont des
écoles des beaux prémices économique
n'existe pas pour la vie un dessin tu
donc les mesures prises par le
gouvernement permettent pas de
stabiliser la situation et de régler les
prophéties de crise des organisations
terroristes de tous niveaux restent la
menace principale la stabilité de la
région
après 1
la débâcle de l'établissement en syrie
en irak les des migrations des
combattants préparer leur migration vers
d'autres pays elle a qui se sont allés
en libye des cellules terroristes
demeurent très actives au mali dans la
république centrafricaine et au
mozambique
il ya toujours des tentatives pour faire
appel aux groupements terroristes pour
démocratiser les pouvoirs dans certains
pays
le renouveau du néo colonialisme l
obtention de contrôle sur les ressources
naturelles ces pays l'utilisation des
terroristes comme un
l'instrumentalisation du terrorisme est
au jeu très dangereux sur l'exemple de
la syrie on pourrait citer des exemples
des cas de thé russe quand d'une
expérience de combat ont pu utiliser
cette période pour préparer des actions
terroristes dans leur pays d'origine
le mystère de la défense et pour le
développement de l'amitié la coopération
mutuellement avantageuse avec l'épée
d'un d'afrique toc depuis les luttes
anticoloniales en afrique l'union
soviétique a toujours soutenu les
mouvements de libération nationale où
son nom de notre histoire commune tous
nous apprécions pour armer les
nombreuses armes et les armées
africaines et enzo coupe des arbres
fabrication soviétique hautement
efficace fiable simple dans leur vous de
ce paysage ses qualités caractérise
également le matériel militaire russe
qui s'est représenté sur le contient
africain jour l'usom des accords de
coopération militaire et ville tor
technique pratiquement avec tous les
pays de cette partie du monde et dans le
cadre du forum
aussi il ya des accords c'est que pour
ouvrir la voie d'une coopération
mutuellement avantageuse la formation au
des cadres à l'implantation des méthodes
de s'avancer pour l'exercice des troupes
et leur formation dans les écoles
militaires soviétiques l'heure toujours
des étudiants venant d'afrique qui sont
formés soit gratuitement soit hors des
conditions avec des bourses
donc nos côtés pour sûr dans ce sens et
pour cent soit l'expérience russe aussi
des jeux des remèdes des jeux de combats
le nombre de concours ou participent les
pays d'afrique du projet orion augmente
sans cesse le meilleur niveau de
formation de spécialistes étrangers dans
les concours les compétitions de l'année
dernière dont l'algérie est la
république de guinée qui qui ont gagné à
ces compétitions nous pensons qu'au
compétition qui nous attendent au jeu le
militaire cette liste sera plus l'eau
des pays participent à cette expérience
sera perçue lors de la formation des
armées nationales nous n'allons pas vers
l'est à qui que ce soit dans la
coopération avec les pays donneurs et je
nous nous opposons nous nous opposons à
personne nous allons accroître des
contrats qui sont et des contacts qui
suit il saura poser nos objectifs nos
conditions politiques économiques colons
font souvent des heures les puissances
occidentales cette même ligne est tout
petit et mise en oeuvre par bercy avec
ses partenaires en amérique latine dans
tous les problèmes mentionnés plus haut
on tire trop sur les autres nous
glissons d'actualité c'est aussi ça la
lutte contre le terrorisme qui est lié à
des coûts tentatives pour initier une
nouvelle série de
deux révolutions colorées donc nous
avons des relations de partenariat avec
cuba le nicaragua et d'autres pays
pendant des années ces pays on résiste à
toutes les formes de pression jusqu'à la
menace de recourir ouvertement à la manu
mali militari donc cela aussi ça
implique la nécessité de former d'armé
de près par mail y aurait le niveau des
combattants et combattantes le led
oui aujourd'hui est plus que jamais
sollicitée aujourd'hui donc ces
dernières années il ya une tendance est
positive coopération avec bolivie et
brésil pérou l'argentine en uruguay et
paraguay club paraguayo de bonnes
perspectives de dialogue pour assurer la
sécurité dans les régions polaires
arctique utilisant le matériel est
surtout les particularités de formation
dans des conditions particulièrement
dures les motos logiquement des médocs
les équipes qui participent au jeu
[Musique]
armez vous aider à la coopération entre
les ministères de la défense et pour
améliorer la
le côté de sécurité s'alarmaient
quelques mois sur la situation en europe
il ya aujourd'hui tendance stable de
face-à-face militaire le bloc north
atlantic au maroc le nom de groupement
militaire de fort niveau d'alerté fort
il ya des titulaires se prépare pour le
transport des troupes vers les
frontières de l'état veut allier de rue
cible de russie puis le jeu de dés fins
de vieil homme pendant ces exercices ont
trouvé des os et des opérationnels de
l'alliance
il est une activité plus intense dans
l'arctique le sommet de l'otan qui se
tenait à bruxelles le 14 juin confirmait
les transformations du blogauto de bloc
régional double creux regroupement
militaro politique mondiale qu'il s'agit
qui voudraient à contenir la russie la
chine les décisions prises ce forum pour
les dépenses aux militaires
l'amélioration du potentiel de
dissuasion nucléaire nucléaire qu'il
fait la face à face militaire le
dialogue global que c'est nous propose
dans le cadeau de la dir-ce ne baisse
pas la tension dans les relations
bilatérales d'autant plus que bien des
pays d'europe ont intérêt à l'escaladé
conflit avec la russie et à titre
d'exemple on pourrait citer le petit
stade les craintes y à la veille du
sommet de bruxelles
yves roussel a provoqué une nouvelle
crise dans le dos de basses dans
l'ensemble situation en europe est
explosive
ce qu'ils demandaient pas coqueret pour
la désescalade dans le sens d'une
désescalade mesures ont été proposées
par les russies notamment au niveau de
la ligne de contact
en continuation on a aussi la
déclaration du président russe
sur la décision relative aux missiles de
portée intermédiaire développer
installés en europe et ceux ci
représentent une menace
surtout si elles peuvent être équipées
d'ogives nucléaires
nous espérons que nous constatons que
les pays européens se retrouvent à
nouveau pieds et mains liés devant les
décisions américaines et le président
poutine avait proposé 2 d'adopter un
certain nombre de mesures pour restaurer
la compense la confiance et supprimer
les motifs de préoccupation il a été la
russie est accusé d'avoir installé des
missiles dans la région de kaliningrad
et menacé menacer les intérêts des états
unis et de la pologne
il est nécessaire d'améliorer la base
juridique de façon à protéger les
équipages d'avions et de bateaux pour
éviter les situations conflictuelles et
cela pourrait être ajoutée aux mesures
actuelles de descons fiction il s'agit
de continuer à travailler dans ce
domaine concernant les autres accords et
traités de contrôle des armements
nous les considérons su comme suffisant
pour permettre de prendre des mesures
normal 2
formation militaire les étapes
supplémentaires pourront être adoptés
après le
une baisse des tensions dans ce niveau
là le contrôle des armements dépend pour
beaucoup des états unis et la rencontre
récente de genève entre les présidents
russe et américain a confirmé la
nécessité d'un dialogue stratégique à
beaucoup de questions se sont accumulés
en la matière et il est nécessaire de
prendre en compte les préoccupations et
les intérêts des deux côtés les experts
du ministère de la défense de la
fédération de russie sont prêts à
travailler en la matière mesdames
messieurs la conférence de moscou ouvre
de nouvelles portes pour le
développement et le renforcement de la
stabilité un certain nombre de problèmes
régionaux qui étaient prioritaires avant
la pandémie père d'un petit peu de leurs
priorités les armes hypersonique les les
innovations numériques et sert à la
cybercriminalité la militarisation de
l'espace tout cela ce sont des thèmes
qui reste d'actualité
un certain nombre de pays aujourd'hui
s'intéresse à la militarisation de
l'espace et aujourd'hui il ya la
préoccupation de prévenir toute attaque
les l'attitude envers les obligations
internationales et les usages des
tensions des sanctions et l'apparition
de nouvelles règles de jeu qui repose
sur des principes qui doivent leur
demeure assez flou tout cela est bien
plus dangereux que ce qu'on voyait
l'époque de la guerre froide nous voyons
dans le monde entier et les militaires
partout dans le monde comprenne bien que
la guerre est un malheur le grand
chantre de l'humanisme rostropovitch
le disais je mettrais un orchestre sur
la ligne de front et je commencerai à
jouer pour que tout le monde dépose les
armes
à l'époque de sa proposition il y avait
des questions qui étaient bien et on
comprend que il avait 11 ans et un
orchestre ce n'est pas seulement un
ensemble de musiciens mais c'est aussi
un ensemble d'experts prêts à travailler
ensemble de concert pour résoudre les
questions et nous avons ici de grands
professionnels en matière de sécurité
qui participent à cette conférence et
cet orchestre d'une certaine façon peut
travailler à trouver des solutions pour
éviter des guerres partout dans le monde
je vous souhaite un travail fructueux et
un excellent séjour dans la ville de
moscou ville héros de la guerre
je vous remercie la parole est donnée
aux électeurs du service fédéral de
sécurité le général alexandre bortnikov
chers collègues
mesdames messieurs avant tout je
voudrais remercier les organisateurs de
la conférence de m'avoir permis de
participer à ces travaux dans la mesure
où le renforcement de la sécurité à
l'international est bien évidemment une
priorité pour tous les pays
les défis qui existait avant la pandémie
de corne à virus demeure toujours
il s'agit du terrorisme de l'extrémisme
ils n'ont pas disparu
et l'activité des groupes armés de
l'état islamique d'al qaïda et d'autres
groupes extrémistes au moyen-orient et
en afrique continue d'être actif
il y a aussi des préoccupations dans
l'asie du sud-est où l'un dernière les
attentats n'ont pas à cesser les
victimes du terrorisme et de
l'extrémisme religieux sont aussi les
villes d'inde un certain nombre de pays
d'europe
malgré toutes les mesures
antiterroristes qui ont été prises on
voit que ces terroristes ces groupes
terroristes continuent à être actif être
opérant ils sont capables de se
déconcentrer de se répartir et de
s'évanouir dans la nature et donc il si
il faut un soutien important
il n'y a pas un manque d'armements et de
munitions les moyens de technologies qui
sont à la disposition il ya des drones
etc tout cela fait partie de la des
conséquences des mesures et des groupes
terroristes soutenus par certains pays
et qui poursuivent des objectifs
terroristes
ces extrémistes et terroristes ne
cherche pas du tout à limiter leur
expansion
il cherche de nouveaux soutiens dans les
pays développés il s'adapte parfaitement
aux à la situation qui a évolué au cours
de l'année dernière dans le monde et on
a ici un effet
collatérales des restrictions imposées
par la pandémie est donc là les zones
les allemands forces et par tous a
provoqué un petit peu une exacerbation
de ses sentiments par ton et ses
manifestations
je manifeste sur le plan économique mais
aussi sur la santé des personnes et 7
ce caractère de risque et de menaces se
constate dans les sociétés de différents
pays et les la propagande sur internet
se poursuit
elle vise les catégories les plus
faibles les plus vulnérables de la
société et notamment ceux dont la
situation matérielle s'est dégradée ces
dernières années et aujourd'hui le
réseau international voit le
développement d'infrastructures qui
favorise l'apparition du terrorisme
notamment près de la jeunesse et dont la
faiblesse psychologique fait que
l'apparition de nouvelles cellules
terroristes sur la base de jeux
informatiques qui peut apparaître donc
ici on a c'est qu'on vous constatez même
la création de clown de ces jeux vidéos
qui permettent de recruter des
volontaires pour la lutte terroriste
c'est à dire que des jeunes sont
entraînés dans ces situations
ressemblant à ceux qu'ils voient dans
les jeux vidéo et cette chasse sur
internet vise particulièrement la
jeunesse on voit des enfants des
écoliers des étudiants qui se sont
retrouvés longtemps isolé est soumis au
régime d'enseignement à distance qui se
sont retrouvés plongés dans des sociétés
internet et qui ont manifesté soit des
formes de ce site soit des formes
d'agressions vis-à-vis des autres de
l'orage et nous voyons comme solution
ici un renforcement de la législation
dans le but de protéger la jeunesse
contre l'apparition de nouvelles modes
d'action au niveau de l'enseignement
dans les établissements d'enseignement
et pour revenir à la question de
l'extrémisme religieux
je voudrais attirer votre attention sur
une autre tendance négative a paru dans
le contexte de distanciation social
c'est l'isolément l'apparition d'
enclave de certaines diapora diaspora
dans les différentes sociétés et on qui
se distinguent par leur gré le rejet des
normes sociales des pays dans lesquels
elles sont et c'est là que le terrorisme
international mène sa propagande de
façon plus efficace pour provoquer des
attentats et 7 radiculaire
radicalisation de la population se
constate au niveau des relations avec
les immigrés on voit l'augmentation des
la glorification des idées nazies
l'augmentation de la populace de
l'influencé de l'extrême droite et on
voit aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui de plus en plus de
justification du nazisme et cela est
parfois introduit au niveau des
politiques nationales et ses
organisations politisé permettent aux
activistes d'extrême droite d'autres
pays de se préparer et de organiser des
camps d'entraînement je voudrais
souligner est que si l'or leur état les
néo nazis sont des ennemis des musulmans
juré que sur le
le territoire des pays tiers il coopère
avec les islamistes radicaux il faut la
guerre dans les troupeaux dans le cadre
des formations paramilitaires le
terrorisme bird marc terroristes
demeurent telles quelles que soient ses
mots d'ordre en russie aussi nous le
temps sans merci contre toutes formes de
terrorisme
la même approche c'était la même
approche que j'appelle nos collègues
grande masse de mars et l'extension le
resserrement des liens entre les
structures de rist internationale dans
la communauté de hackers et leurs
activités dans le cyberespace de
terrorisme ne peuvent pas l'os des cyber
attaques sur des ouvrages
d'infrastructures critiques ce titre il
est extrêmement dangereux serait
complexité de localiser la source de
l'attaqué
la possibilité de provoquer des conflits
entre états de ce problème global ne
pourra être résolue sans toute la
communauté internationale nous estimons
nécessaire qui doit éteindre le
processus de négociation pour harmoniser
les normes juridiques internationales
dans le cadre de la sécurité numérique
sous l'égide de l'onu nous sommes prêtes
à la au dialogue avec tous les
partenaires qui souhaitent un espace
un cyber espace sécurisé chef distingué
participe à lille existe en russie un
système de lutte contre toutes les
terroristes la prophylaxie la prévention
et la liquidation séquelles donc c'était
lors de la conception de la lutte qu
entité russe dans la fédération de
russie où le rôle clé au nord au comité
anti du ris maintenant c'est un
organisme interministériel qui coordonne
les activités à tous les niveaux du
pouvoir
inde et à des collectivités locales qui
est de il faudra donc améliorer la base
juridique et faire appel à toutes les
institutions de la société civile la
manière c'est la politique nationale
dans la lutte contre l'extrémisme la
dernière on a adopté une nouvelle
version de stratégie nationale de lutte
contre le terrorisme la réunification
des états des efforts de l'état et de
société permet de faire durer la
tendance à la baisse des attentats
terroristes avec nos savoir faire
avec nos prévisions nos pronostics
les experts de ce copieux en théorie ce
nous les partageons avec nos partenaires
dans le cadre du comitat qui théorisent
de l'onu j'appelle aussi dans cette
optique dans d'autres formats en mettant
l'accent sur des décisions communes à
caractère préventif
tout d'abord il s'agit je parle à la
résistance à la propagande sur internet
de l'idéologie de violence où nous
voyons une des causes fondamentales de
la reproduction de leur surgissement du
terrorisme nous savons d'expérience
qu'on pourra pas éradiquer complètement
le terrorisme l'extrémisme en dix ans
seulement des escrimeurs de force il
faudra mener la guerre pour les esprits
de nos citoyens pour empêcher la
formation des scottishs très haut niveau
en informant sur scène où la société
dans laquelle l'associé de seraient
protégés contre les sio des structures
ses mystères
christelle faudra aussi coopérer
largement pour faire obstacle
l'utilisation par le virus du
cyber-espace à faire participer les
ressources financières notamment de
coordonnées de loin l'actif de leur
cellule terroriste donc pour tous les
participants à cette conférence
il est absolument évident que dans le
mode moderne qu'un état ne tenez
garantie contre
terrorisme a donc pour y résister il
faudra le faire en commun le terme à l
allure c'est comme une lutte commune
c'est tout d'amour ce tome et charge des
formations préventive et toute
information nécessaire aussi que des
zecs des opérations anti terroristes et
extrémistes notamment
nous proposons à nos partenaires
d'utiliser plus largement de ressources
de labarde internationale de lutte
contre le terrorisme
à titre d'exemple de mon contact je
confierai sur celle cô té ka qui
théorisent de l'onu
la structure antiterroriste deux de
l'organisation de shanghai a dressé oui
donc les conférences à nivelles des
services de sécurité et des mesures
police des partenaires de fsb la russie
ne participe en toutes les parties
intéressées un dialogue objecteurs joue
au chrtr pour le têt contre le
terrorisme cers nous sont ouvertes dans
tous les autres domaines
le pour la sécurité internationale
ce je souhaite aux participants au forum
un travail a fracturé je vous remercie
de votre attention
le majeur et pyromane est assez
ambitieux
le match est pénible
zani trimestre amasser des fonds on
dessine
oui
mesdames et messieurs bonjour bourdon la
première session plénière de la deuxième
conférence sur la sécurité
internationales de moscou
et en guise du sujet de notre première
session plénière nous avons choisi le
sujet de la stabilité stratégique leurs
collègues à la situation actuelle dans
le monde tant changements rapides le
monde fait face à de nouveaux défis à la
sécurité la pandémie elle est menacé
bernetti le terrorisme international
la propagation incontrôlable de des
armes de destruction massive la
l'apparition de nouvelles technologies
et de nouveaux types de désarment fort à
une liste non excessive de ces menaces
il y a une semaine le 16 juin à genève
le sujet de la stabilité stratégique à
deux centres de l'agent dot et de
l'intrus cyan des länder de l'est russie
des états unis je tiens à souligner que
durant ce sommet les leaders ont abordé
une déclaration commune a déclaré dire
le début du dialogue la stabilité
stratégique
à cet égard il me semble pas opportun de
discuter aujourd'hui à notre forum à
cette question prioritaire de sécurité
globale bazot
au sujet de notre science plénière nous
proposons de parler au sujet de la
stabilité stratégique évidemment en les
tendances de leur transformation
permettez moi de vous présenter le
panéliste aujourd'hui le général d'armée
valérie gasimov chef de l'état major
général des forces armées de la
fédération de russie le premier adjoint
du ministre de la défense de la
fédération de russie
le général de division ukrainienne liste
la défense de la république de
biélorussie à pied terme à vera
président du comité international de
croix rouge général de free gardes du
corps des gardes de la révolution
islamique
l'ex président de la british amis de
gagner ce temps il sera avec nous en
téléconférence à partir de kaboul dans
cette session plénière nous présentons
aussi l'adresser vidéo du ministre de la
défense de la république de chine
je décolle pour débuter je tiens à
adresser demande à nos intervenants
je vous demande de suivre la durée de 10
minutes
vos interventions
nous prévoyons de l'inter terminer le
travail de notre session à 11h30 heure
et je passe des paroles chef de l'état
major général des forces armées de la
fédération de russie général d'armée
valérie guerassimova si mauvais
et donc commandant expérimenté en
constance de novembre 2012
gillet et chef de l'état major général
des forces armées et les décors et de
décoration supérieur l'étoile dorée du
héros de la fédération de russie
je passais parole général guerassimova
mesdames et messieurs la victoire de la
coalition anti syrienne en 1945 et à
créer des conditions pour créer en nous
faut un nouvel ordre mondial de
développement sans conflit des relations
entre les pays mais les espoirs de
l'humanité pour la coexistence pacifique
et ne se sont pas réalisées la décision
de l'otan au bout - pour créer le temps
a fait le premier pas pour diviser le
monde en deux camps opposés et
l'humanité s'est vu confronté en guerre
froide la pression de l'armé nucléaire
et à son usage
on par les états unis contre le japon
donné l'exemple de la menace de passage
à la phase active de cette guerre froide
a dominé mais toutes les mesures que la
flotte et des stratégies coeur entre les
camps opposés
enfin on a su signer les accords dans le
domaine de sers de désarmer moi qui ont
servi à lille
et le concerné mans nucléaire sont les
cités c'est le liberté contre les
missiles contre les anti missile le
comtat le contrat est comme un élément
de sa vérification l'accord ciel ouvert
nous avons signé une série des traités
pour limiter contredit les armes
stratégiques et l'effondrement de
l'union soviétique
ça fait changer le pignon de l'otan sur
les questions de sécurité globale
l'occident a pris corps vérité la
création du monde unipolaire siens la
supériorité et dans le domaine militaire
et les âges de la force pour la
promotion de ces enterré on a vu des
exemples de cette politique yougoslavie
racing and east en libye et en syrie
aussi l'aspiration de veauche hington à
faire disparaître toutes sortes de
l'imitation d'un mot domaines de
développement de l'armement fait que les
états unis ceux des prétextes conquet
ont quitté le le traité d anti missiles
ont quitté le crédit était un missile de
petite et moyenne portée et traité de
si élevés qu'ils ont quitté en 2000 dans
le traité des forces conventionnelles en
europe n'a pas été air est ratifié par
les pays européens
cet été on servile de créer le système
de contrôle des armements et on serre et
à renforcer la confiance entre les états
ont prouvé leur efficacité
actuellement le seul cette convention
internationale qui servent à maintenir
ce serait me l'étais stratégique c'est
le pt sur les plaisirs de réductions et
limitations des armes offensives
stratégiques
il s'agit de j'ai traité start son
prolongement cinq ans jusqu'à 2020 6 on
a vu la situation stabilisée et je tiens
aussi souligné qu à la prolongation de
ce traité devenu possible grâce à la
volonté de la russie et des états unis
les deux pays sont intéressés à voir des
relations prédictible dans le domaine de
développement de fureur une aide et en d
autres à la présence des mesures de
contrôle assure ce prédictibilité la
prolongation de ce traité nous servira
de base à réanimer le dialogue vu de
nouveaux facteurs qui déterminent la
stabilité stratégique landes de ce
facteur important c'est la création des
deux nouvelles armement il comprit
désarmement hyper sonic et cinétique de
précisions y compris des drones de
combat ce qui ferait disparaître les
limites entre les potentiels des armes
nucléaires et un conventionnel
les tendances à en force mans du rôle
dollars mammifères durant conflit des
tas faisant appel uniquement à des armes
conventionnelles à est reflété dans la
doctrine nucléaire des états unis
récemment adopté à cet égard d'éléments
importants pour la station à la statue
et et stratégiques iris la dissuasion
nucléaire dissuasion nucléaire a servi
d'assurer la stabilité la sécurité des
rues durant les dernières décennies et
durant les crises pourquoi très féroce
c'est l'opinion officielle de la russie
et des thalys et des clercs du pas son
public en 2020 à la base de la politique
d'état de la fédération de russie dans
le domaine de la dissuasion nucléaire ce
document aussi bien que la doctrine
militaire pays du monde le statut
d'adversaire militaire de la russie à la
base de notre doctrine secte ur
politique nucléaire de notre pire rester
uniquement défensive la fédération de
russie se réserve le droit de faire
appel à l'armé nucléaire en réponse à
l'usagé contre elle compte cézallier de
larmes ou nucléaires ou d'autres types
d'armes de destruction massive y compris
et aussi en cas d'agression contre la
fédération de russie avec plus de
pression de leurs conventionnelle si l
existence même de d'état et mise en
danger au contenu
la désagrégation du système de contrôle
des armements le temps on continue
continue la progression de ces entre
structures après des frontières
nationales de la fédération theo ici on
off et on en a vu des exemples de la
caisse de la pression des contingents
sur les territoires des pays limitrophes
ces forces de réaction rapide et ceux à
10 ans comprennent détachement ans
thierry et de l'infanterie russie là le
personnel total est plus de 6000
personnes est déployée par le temps
passe les frontières y compris le
contingent des pays occidental après des
frontières sera augmentée ce que nous
prouve un accord signale années passées
entre washington et par celui qui
prévoit le déploiement supplémentaire
sur le territoire polonais des organes
de commandement et des forces spéciales
et des face à jean ii le temps la
pratique et de création d'équipements
militaires visant à renforcer son
influence est d'utiliser par les états
unis non seulement en europe mais dans
d'autres régions du monde y compris de
l'asie pacifique pour la sécurité
internationale
les problèmes de la lutte anti missile
devient de plus en plus importants
ministres chaud bouillant de déjà parler
le facteur de la défense antimissile
influence directement la lutte aux
armements et les dépendances assure la
stabilité stratégique actuellement les
éléments de la lutte anti missile
américaine et menaces sont déployés en
europe et dans les régions de 2
le pacifique les etats unis continuent à
les renforcer en créant des ans des
systémes atterrissent tre antimissile en
pologne et le renforcement de leurs
éléments des bâtiments de guerre de
l'otan pour des raisons difficiles nous
avons en plusieurs fois prêté
l'attention de nos partenaires à cet
effet qui ne sert que déstabiliser la
situation actuelle l'affluence de la
défense antimissile des etats-unis à
notre potentiel militaire nous a fait
pousser un coup perfectionner notre
armement pour faire face à cette menace
il ne faut pas oublier et les forces de
combat de frappes de l'otan
les croisières tomahawks être lancées
par des rampes de lancement anniversaire
cac 41 qui font partie des systèmes
antimissile déployé en roumanie et comme
je viens de dire qu'ils seront déployés
récemment sur le territoire à polonais
la base et technologique créa pendant
fonctionnement du traité contre les
missiles depuis de moyens de porter à
cerner du mans a le temps pour déployer
les missiles dans notre région
en cas de réussite de ce programme les
etats unis ont renforcé la menace aux
différentes sites sur le territoire us
la marine de le temps
et de plus en plus actif dans la mer
noire et la mer baltique
nous ne voyons la présence des bâtiments
de guerre armée l'idée de l'armement de
haute précision de haute puissance
les vols de reconnaissance
réalisé par des heures 9 et des drones
sont de plus en plus multiple les
actions des états unis et de leurs
alliés sont de plus en plus pour voir
qui on le 13 octobre de l'année passée
le navire dragonne de la grande bretagne
avec des radars de commandes de tirs est
elle de supervision qui ont été
branchées à violi frontières nationales
près de sébastopol le vent 4 octobre un
autre navire des états unis john mccain
a violé à la frontière nationale de la
fédération de russie dans la mer un
japonais près de vladivostok en
pénétrant dans les eaux territoriales
russes à plus de deux kilomètres
nous voyons les tentatives de créer les
premiers les incidents ce qui ne
renforce pas la stabilité du tout encore
en facteurs qui ont influencé la ddt
stratégique c'est le linge y semant des
zones d'activités des forces armées li
avec le ch les changements climatiques
et y compris et notamment la zone est il
qu'hier alors les tendances actuelles
sans l'implication de ces zones
arctiques dans l'activité économique
qu'ils font un certain pays
essayez
de réviser les pratiques existantes
usage des ressources de la région
on voit aussi s'activer l'activité des
êtes un régional et extérieurs qui qui
ne font qu'augmenter le nombre des
exercices militaires y compris navales
près de la frontière leur ticket sert à
assurer la communication la plus courte
entre la fédération de russie et
d'autres continents il s'agit de cet os
x maritime du nord et la russie dispose
de tout ce qu'il faut pour assurer le
respect de ses intérêts dans la zone
arctique à la confrontation en milieu
informatique sont douces sont de plus en
plus féroce et nombreuses
les technologies informatiques sont
utilisés en guise d'armes haut pour
apporter des dommages à des sites dans
trois structures des états la fédération
de russie a pris la position successives
contre à l' usage de réseaux
informatiques indécent militaire
l'importance inclus appartient au
dialogue en internationales pour créer
un régime légal sous l'égide de l'onu
qui servira à créer des conditions à
prévenir et régler les conflits dans le
milieu global informatique n'aurait les
on se crève a du poids sans tifo cendres
le nu au sens de l'organisation de
coopération de shanghai de brix et de
l'organisation de l'organisation du
traité de sécurité collective non
proposons de déployer des efforts pour
renforcer la confiance dans le zoo dans
le domaine informatique
nous continuons la lutte contre le
terrorisme international en syrie en
irak
les groupements de bêche sont plutôt
anéantie mais un aux témoignages le
transit des théories ce à partir du
proche orient vers l'afrique du nord et
en afghanistan
il est à noter qu'un série des ong et
des services spéciaux de surtemps pays
participent à financer et à armer les
organismes terroristes en essayant d'en
profiter pour promouvoir leurs intérêts
apolitique mais l'expérience nous montre
que les yeux avec les terroristes ne
font jamais du bien au total les
terroristes se déchaîne et l'essentiel
sécu c'est seulement avec la
coordination entre et cela compte pour
lutter contre le terrorisme
chers collègues à la situation qui est
dans le monde ne fait que démontrer que
le temps de domination unilatérale a
déjà au passé
le nombre des états qui disposent d'un
potentiel économique et militaire
important s'agrandit et actuellement on
ne peut plus rejoindre des questions
d'importance sans leur participation
il s'agit de lave du brésil de l'inde de
la chine russie et les etats unis des
pays de l'union européenne et d'autres
pays qui
sans les centres de force à l'échelle
régionale et mondiale et la quantité de
ses à payer nous sommes sûrs que plus
grande de demain là le monde actuel a
fait face à des menaces multiples
contrôles et l'escale à sion et
interdire les hostilités surtout entre
eux les pays disposant de l'armé
nucléaire c'est une mission qui devient
de plus en plus compliqué nous croyons
que nous pouvons profiter nous pouvons
promouvoir la stabilité internationale
en limitant la course aux armements
rendez-vous le pont les mesures pour
faire en force et notre confiance disant
aux autres en essayant de régler d'une
façon politique économique et les
conflits régionaux pour interdire le
conflit il faut ancrer et entend défier
les communications entre les militaires
de différents pays
ça me servira de réduire la tension et
éviter les incidents
nous poursuivrons notre travail pour
garantir la non prolifération d'armes
nucléaires et interdire l'accès à ces
termes et man 2 premiers de vos pays
on nous resterons fidèles au traité de
non prolifération de l'armé nucléaire
nous croyons qu'il est important
d'arriver là
destruction du système actuel de
contrôle des armements
avant tout il faut attirer l'attention
particulière au respect des traités
existants dans le domaine perspective
depuis nous il faut perfectionner les
mécanismes visant à assurer la stabilité
stratégique en leur attribuant le
caractère multidimensionnel
aujourd'hui il est important que tous
les pays faisant appel à leurs sages et
c est la volonté politique c'est comme
instrument cette responsabilité que les
russies a proposé d'organiser de semer
des pays pendant la majeure
responsabilité pour le maintien de la
paix dans le but de confirmer les ponts
clé dans les relations internationales
et criaient des quarts des routeurs pour
résoudre les conflits actuels
le ministère de la défense la fédération
de russie est prêt à contacter à titre
égal
rg avec le plein respect avec nos
partenaires et notre conférence en sert
une bonne plateforme pour animer ce
dialogue je veux remercier de votre
attention
un chéri je vous remercie a pour deux
estimations bien fondé de l'expression
stratégique dans le monde
maintenant j'aimerais vous donner la
parole et et vous présenter le message
du ministre de défense de chine et le
général de corps van keer qui depuis
marcel 2018 occupe son poste est où ici
le membre du conseil d'état et les
ministres de la défense de la république
et de défense chinoise de base et les
non spécialistes en missile qui a
franchi toutes les étapes de
développement de l'est de l'armée de
défense de la chine et qui a visité
notre pays avec plusieurs fois pendant
les visites officielles maintenant à
présenter un message vidéo merci
beaucoup
cher monsieur ministre de la défense
sergueï choïgou messieurs et mesdames
chers collègues je veux vous remercier
pour la possible d'intervenir lors de la
9ème conférence de moscou sur la
sécurité internationale
cette confiance c'est une plateforme
importante pour changer l'expérience est
les opinions pour interagir dans le
domaine de la sécurité n'est
international qui joue un rôle
importante pour consolider la stabilité
et la paix internationales et sert d'une
plateforme pour échanger de l'expérience
et jour une rôle est primordial afin
d'assurer la sécurité et la stabilité
internationale aujourd'hui je vais
intervenir avec mon message où je vais
parler des problèmes de la stabilité de
la sécurité
tout d'abord c'est la pandémie du cornât
virus et qui s'est accumulée avec les
problèmes de l'humanité universel
aujourd'hui le destin commun réunit nous
tous
seulement lyon l interaction nos
permettront en commun de dépasser
surmonter ses difficultés pour nous
retrouver au futur et le conquérir
évidemment nous voyons d'un
développement progressif avec et
décadence et et des rythmes élevés
pendant que la pandémie fait le
détriment au le bien-être des peuples et
des pays du monde entier
nous voyons l'augmentation de la
stabilité de la situation internationale
et surtout pendant cette période et
historique de turbulences et la
construction du destin commun de
l'humanité universel et répond aux défis
de l'époque et représente un chemin de
bonne foi pour couvrir et protéger les
intérêts de tous les pays et de tous les
peuples du monde entier
la pandémie a fait un choc contre nous
tous et nous devons nous réunir tous
pour nous soutenir les uns les autres
d'un seul coup la pandémie a fait un
choc énorme à la communauté universelle
parce que nous vivons pendant la
deuxième année par les conditions du
conte à bruxelles et le monde entier
fait face à cette menace et la chine
fait de son mieux pour prévenir et
contrôler il n'ya pas d'ennemis à son
tour et a présenté plus de 170 et pays
et organisations du monde entier
un grand nombre de vaccins et des
médicaments de la lutte contre le corps
navires us ce que nous pourrions nommer
en tant que grande assistance
humanitaire de la république populaire
de chine
depuis l'apparition de l'infection
pendant que certains pays continuent à
jouer des rôles est politique et à
stigmatiser tous les efforts de lutte
contre les pandémies et font la
promotion de ce qu'on appelle le virus
politique dans le contexte de la lutte
contre la pandémie
aucun pays ne peut rester en sécurité et
tranquille avant que le virus soit
combattu pendant et partout dans le
monde entier pendant son histoire
l'humanité a fait face aux menaces et et
cette fois ci nous allons
surtout remporté les victoires si nous
comptions à jouer en commun en
réunissant nos efforts pendant cette
lutte contre le corps navires us ensuite
le l'ordre mondial fait face aux menaces
et défis d'importance où nous devons
toujours soutenir les principes de
l'inégalité parce que le monde
contemporain etc a réalisé par
l'apparition de phénomènes chaotique
dont les raisons se trouve en fait qu'un
seul pouvoir
n'oublions du tout qui en se fixant
juste la proche de la lutte de la guerre
froide utilise la politique est de
l'approché unilatéralisme est de
l'intervention surtout ce pays fait la
pression de son opinion aux autres pif
et l'ingérence aux activités des autres
états et sous aucun prétexte et son
prétexte fait la politique toujours de
dissuasion de blocage fait apparaître
des sanctions et les impose en mini
plomb l'opinion publique et surtout
quand sur des révolutions de couleur
afin de faire changer les pouvoirs
légitimes dans certains pays du monde et
manipulent l'opinion publique et pour la
discréditer les activités
légitime et ce qui fait le monopole pour
limiter le développement des autres pays
et pour cette raison nous devons faire
face tous ensemble à cette approche pour
protéger le système universel sous
l'égide de l'onu et protéger le droit
international et soutenir le rôle de
l'onu dans les activités internationales
pour sécuriser et les relations
internationales
en troisième lieu j'aimerais noter que
certains risques à la sécurité à la
stabilité ne font qu'augmenter
nous devons toujours suivre les
principes de consultation de
compréhension mutuelle et les principes
de coexistence
car actuellement le monde n'était pas
stable n'est pas sécurisé et la
compétition entre différents pays
s'aggrave et les guerres et les conflits
régionaux n'ont pas disparu surtout nous
voyons augmenter les attaques des
hackers et surtout qui représente menace
à la sécurité internationale
aujourd'hui deviennent de plus en plus
compliqué et pour cette raison c'est
toujours est important de suivre saint
principe pendant que ce pays
en simple en un policier mondial
un gendarme mondial veut tout sauf la
paix et la sécurité mondiales ne fait
qu'apparaître des blocs pour faire la
politique de dissuasion qui provoque des
menaces militaires partout et la partie
chinoise considère réponse que en
appliquant et en utilisant des
consultations commune il y en discutant
de cette question nous pourrons toujours
aller chez le mondial et réseaux dreux
toutes les tiges et poursuivre la
principe
de la sécurité d'ensemble pour tous pour
approfondir la coopération et assurer la
paix durable pour nous tous j'aimerais
porter et attirer votre attention sur
notre aspect de la paix et de
développement
ce qui représente une tendance commune
de tous les peuples ou la chine fait une
grande contribution pour promouvoir le
développement universel dont la racine
l'approchent ouverte au développement
commun donnant donnant et la chine en
tant qu une grand pouvoir travailler
toujours pour le thé ignorer les progrès
de toute l'humanité et jour en tant que
constructeur pour assurer la paix sur la
planète approuve protéger l'ordre
mondial
et dans ce contexte est j'aimerais
souligner le fait que nous sommes prêts
à porter plus de contribution à la
prospérité de toute la planète parce que
la chine fait tout de son mieux et vise
à assurer la paix universelle et fait
attention non seulement pour assurer sa
propre au développement mais pour
assurer le bien-être universel et
surtout sur le fond de la pandémie
la chine fait face au problème et f
faits démontrés de grands progrès dans
la prévention de la propagation de la
pandémie et j'ai eu un grand rôle dans
la promotion des affaires mondiales et
sur le plan économique est la chine
démontre aussi des yachts des succès
surtout dans la lutte contre la pauvreté
et joe une grande contribution pour
assurer et favoriser la lutte contre la
pandémie et la restauration après la
pandémie des ménages
et des économies nationales de
différents pays du monde
la chine a fait un grand saut dans les
domaines de haute technologie comme le
développement des porteurs des vaisseaux
spatiaux
la colonisation du mars et la
contribution économique de la chine a
dépassé 30% aujourd'hui la chine c'est
un grand partenaire pour plus de 120
pays de la région du monde entier et la
construction commune ban bertranne rodez
parce que c'est un concept central de
cette construction démontre les progrès
de ces tendances est de 7 à pro chinoise
actuellement nous célébrons le 100e
anniversaire du parti communiste chinois
cette année et pour cette raison la
communauté des ménages moyens a été déjà
créé et est passé pour cette raison nous
visons pour assurer le développement
universel pour tous pas ce qu'ils ont
actuellement la chine porte l'accent sur
le développement de l'économie interne
et la promotion à l'intérieur à
l'extérieur de ses activités économiques
en deuxième lieu j'aimerais souligner le
fait que nous appliquons plus d'efforts
pour assurer l'égalité universelle parce
qu aucun pays du monde ne peut fait que
regarder le développement université de
l'immunité et résoudre les estampes des
autres peuples parce que les problèmes
globaux doit être résolu par des
consultations commune et ne sont
toujours pour la prochain non ce monde
du multilatéralisme mais nous agissons
pour le conseil du 2 v les
développements la construction comment
et répartition des ressources eux
commune ainsi que nous voulons assurer
une un ordre communauté interationale
plus juste et plus et qu'il aimerait
bien ce que la chine aujourd'hui est le
membre de toutes les organisations
internationales et a fait part pour plus
de 106 traités internationaux et passé
plus de 120000 contrat est traités
internationaux
parce que tout ce qui existe sur la
planète appartient à toute l'humanité
dont la chine est toujours le partisan
pas ce que la chine agit pour le progrès
de l'humanité en troisième
nous sommes prêts à démontrer et jouer
un rôle le plus important pour sécuriser
le développement universel et parce que
les la civilisation chinoise a toujours
je vais effet et après que tous ses
efforts pour assurer la paix parce que
l'aspiration vers la paix est devenue
une des tendances central du
développement de la civilisation il
peuple chinois parce que nous avons
jamais provoquer des conflits
internationaux nous avons jamais conquis
des territoires étrangers
peu importe comment le développement va
se poursuivre pour la chine
parce que la chine n'agira jamais en
tant que j'ai monnaie mondiale et cette
détermination ne sont jamais et et
résiste à tous les doutes qui pis est
surgir
parce que la chine investit et envoyé
plus de est 38 lots dead humanitaire et
plus de 120 le bâtiment de guerre pour
assurer le convoi dans le cadre du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu
et sur le convoi plus de 7 millions
navire a ici vie les étrangers chinois a
passé que l'armée chinoise avait
toujours joué le rôle de protecteurs de
la paix un quatrième lieu ne protégeons
toujours les intérêts clés de la chine
est passée que le terreau vannes est une
partie intégrante de la salle d'audience
chinoise et l'unanimité unanimité
chinoise fait partie d'une tendance
historique qui résiste à tous les doutes
éventuels et l'indépendance de taiwan ne
finira pas par jouer un rôle dans
quelques quel que soit positif l'armée
nationale et populaire de défense
chinoise va jouer un rôle primordial
dans cette lutte pour protéger surtout
les attaques contre les régions de
sindian ricour parce qu'il ne fait que
rendre y est sûre et un rôle négatif
notre pays fasse que depuis quatre ans
et qu'en dernier en plus de 4200
fonctionnaires étrangers des diplomates
des médias ils ont tous visiter les
régions à cette année ils ont tous vu ce
qui se passe là-bas les ovules et
prospérité du contrôle et le peuple un
bonnet vie pacifique est ce qu'on
appelle le non-respect la violation des
droits humains n'a aucun place dans
cette région sans parler du génocide
parce que c'est un mensonge un non cash
et surtout les un problème de changan de
ti bête
les problèmes de la mer sur les
chinoises
pour partie des intérêts internes de la
chine
pour cette raison nous sont toujours
absolument contre les tentatives qui
visent à bloquer et faire le détriment
aux intérêts chinois
le troisième aspect d'importance ok
attirer votre attention
c'est la stabilité et la sécurité
globale
est-ce que ça j ai des défis auxquels
nous devons faire face parce qu'une dont
déjà créé la structure de la sécurité
internationale en se fondant sur le
principe de la construction commune et
sur le partage équilibré des ressources
naturelles là parce que les défis
universel site d approche commune pour
faire face à ces risques pour assurer le
développement ultérieur donner tous et
l'armée chinoise en commun avec s es
collègues des autres armées étrangères
sont prêts à assurer ce développement et
assurer la sécurité nationale et
j'aimerais souligner le fait que la
confiance dans le domaine mais les
terres au niveau élevé c'est vraiment un
élément de conjugaison entre nos pays
parmi les plus importants et l'a remis
militaire et chinoise a des contacts
avec plus de 150 armes et militaires du
monde est pour consolider les hamiti
bilatérales et surtout entre les deux
armées comme moi c'est les chinoises et
est rude nos bases on sur les principes
du partenariat et la coopération
stratégique qui joue un rôle clé afin de
promouvoir la stabilité et la paix et
assurer la sécurité internationale et la
chine et l'union européenne
les ont les autres des deux côtés
doivent faire et appliquer leur offre
pas pour protéger
les principes du développement
avantageux pour des deux parties et pour
surmonter les obstacles et qu'ils
puissent surgir à parlant des états unis
à la partie chinoise avec est la partie
américaine en respectant les principes
de coopération bilatérale mutuellement
avantageuse pour consolider les contacts
et faire disparaître les litiges et
promouvoir un développement sain des
relations chinois american bilatérales
et pour l'assuré il faut que les états
unis prennent des pas et des acteurs
pratiquer et la chine
un espoir qui ces relations vont revoir
leur naissance et mots sont toujours
déterminés à assurer notre seule réalité
nationale est dorénavant qu'on parle pas
c'est nous à nous allons toujours
développer la coopération avec les pays
de l'asie du pacifique y compris les
pays du proche orient de l'afrique et de
l'amérique latine pour augmenter les
niveaux de confiance et assurer la
coopération bilatérale un deuxième but
en ce qui concerne le perfectionnement
des plates formes de cotation nous
voyons que sur le fond de la pandémie
nous seront toujours capables d'avoir un
bon contact grâce aux moyens de
communication comme les téléphones
portables des visioconférences les
correspondances et la partie chinoise
est toujours prêt
comme par le passé à continuer à
participer à la conférence de moscou sur
la confiance internationale pour
travailler au format asma plus shangri
la nous sommes toujours prêts à
continuer et poursuivre ses
consultations
parce que l'année en cours c'est aussi
l'anniversaire de leurs questions de
coopération de shanghai et nous sommes
prêts à renforcer
la coopération avec tous les états
membres et tous les observateurs dans le
cas de ce dialogue parce que les parties
chinoises grande importance et attention
à la constrution bilatérales et communes
et des forces armées nous sommes prêts à
faire face en commun aux défis qui
surgissent actuellement la partie
chinoise considéré la possibilité de
réaliser le sommet de beijing et tianjin
ya encore une fois nous sommes prêts à
proposer de nouvelles questions pour
l'âge internationale et nous devons
poursuivre la lutte contre la pandémie
du conte à virus a et la partie chinoise
applique des efforts pour assurer la
distribution équilibrée des vaccins
parmi tous les pays du monde est de plus
en plus de participants de la communauté
internationale ils doivent à avoir accès
à ces médicaments médicaments
extrêmement important dans cette lutte
et l'armée chinoise est prêt à assurer
la contribution dans cette liste pour
renforcer la coopération
l'activité pacifique aussi bien que la
lutte contre le terrorisme
l'aide humanitaire et le sauvetage
nous allons contribuer au développement
de la coopération dans le monde entier
je le remercie de votre attention
zahar seine quai et je vous remercie de
vos évaluations pour les défis et des
menaces actuelles qui sont dignes d'être
analysée et d'avoir toutes autres
intentions mais tant que hôte et
messieurs je passe par la remise de la
défense est bien les rues sur général de
division 1 lecteur krine générale crédit
n'a commencé sa carrière militaire en
1988 à partir de janvier en cours il est
lisse de la défense
en tant que commandant des airs mais il
a promouvoit la renforcement de notre
coopération et le renforcement de la
défense de son pays mesdames et
messieurs je suis persuadé que les
dirigeants comprennent le sens ils
eurent situation actuelle dans le monde
et de prévenir les interventions
précédentes ne font que répondre mais se
taisent je tiens à remercier mes
collègues russes pour ses priorités de
partager mon opinion sur les problèmes
et pisé ii à la sécurité internationale
et à d en avoir fait assez tribune
nous avons constaté qu'il santé de la
guerre ans dans le monde et en irak à
dire en toute sincérité la guerre déjà
commencé et lady jane maison
ce monsieur n'est pas la guerre d'hier
alors ce que des troupes et des soldats
se confrontent sur le champ de bataille
il s'agit d'une guerre bleus proxy ou
thermique globale des élites et
transnationales et les bénéficiaires de
cette guerre font tout pour rester dans
l'ombre
mais non nous les voyons
nous voyons les partisans du monde en
bonis unipolaire seul à deux mètres raté
gouvernement j'ai pendant les prières
entre les zetas se verront c'est la
stratégie du chaos guidée qui à leur
époque
c'est dans ce cadre qu'ont fait appel à
des concepts d un lead et des
résolutions de couleurs la pandémie on
each de cornas virus ne fait que
promouvoir ce chaos c'est les
confinements réalisés dans plusieurs
états ont vu leurs résultats les
économies ont été dégradés les gens
n'ont plus confiance au gouvernement de
leur pays
les gens ont peur pour leur avenir
regardez ce qui se passe dans le monde
les gens descendent dans les rues dans
le monde entier en commençant par
l'europe et les états unis
un allant jusqu'à l'afrique et les îles
du pacifique une vague des révolutions
de couleur a pénétré l'espace
postsoviétique y est on essaie de
détruire les états et les deux sets
repris hier de leur richesse
les répliques de la russie n'a pas fait
d'exception
nous aussi nous avons été impliqués dans
se cache une partie de la société virus
a compris que les sponsors de dallas et
de au street en leur proposant un
nouveau modèle du monde je trouve a pas
de place pour eux
leur patrie pour l'attaqué indépendante
maintenant on appelons toutes les masses
qui ont joie les tentatives de change
l'ordre mondial
la république de biélorussie font tout
autre pays
ce n'est qu'une figure pas sur
l'échiquier de ses plus pour changer de
l'autre mondiale
on ne laissera pas tranquille en luttant
pour le contrôle total sur la planète on
peut voir l'aggravation de la lutte
après la pandémie on perd suivre les
tentatives à démettre les gouvernements
elle est des rendez pendant pour sa
faire des ressources à ses rangs les
rues sur des institutions
internationales de sécurité sont
discrédités sont toujours critiqué pour
ne pas résoudre les problèmes
d'opportunités les inspirations
économiser les piles g durant la
pandémie cela n'a pas contribué à
l'efficacité de ces institutions à
truyes ne sont plus très efficace
situation on trouva aucun soutien à deux
petits pays qui aspire la semaine on
était sur des traités internationaux
dans le domaine de la sécurité
internationale et de contrôler afin de
les traiter des pensions à l'europe
prepare entre les missiles de pied des
moyens et le tri des ciels vers
prévention contre le roi en chimie qu ça
n'existe plus leur disposition sont
systémiquement violet latry taciturne
des organisations internationales
une seule exception c'est ce contraste à
ce qu'ils restent dans la gare de la
sécurité mondiale les états et les
structures privées sont de plus en plus
nombreux à essayer de développer de
votive d'aaron destruction massive on a
repris les travaux dans le domaine de
l'ingénierie kheder biologie et des
environs de pékin nous au fond attirer
votre attention sur un la menace qui
plus j'irai dans lire laboratoire des
pays de l'ex urss
ce sont les représentants de fonte à
gosnay qui sans mettre maintenant
j'espère que cette pandémie decoded dont
la source restaient inconnues même
couvre l'organisation mondiale de santé
que ce flou que ce flot contemporain
furent à la communauté internationale à
comprendre les menace si j c
les fortes du monde les grandes
puissances se sentent invincibles est en
puni en franchissant les rouges on peut
dire qu'il s'agit d'un terrorisme est
pratiqué le premier c'était à l'heure le
meurtre par les américains en général y
régnant sésame qui s'amusent il y a
quelques mois public aimait les russies
a aussi connu des chutes de ne pas payer
au cours de l'opération combinés des
forces spéciales parce que spécial de la
russie de biélorussie roma su arrêter en
contredisant tard c'est évident que le
russe et des membres de sa famille mais
l'anc est trouvé des preuves
irrésistible de participation j'ai
structure américaine dans ce complot
quatrième de plus en plus souvent dans
les médias nous voyons publié les
pronostics destination des situations et
les résultats des beautés simulait
si on dit s'il était à toute sorte de
théâtre fait cette idée que les
présentations à armer c'est normal c'est
la normalité non bâton simultanément on
fait l'amour et de nouvelles formes et
nos méthodes de faire la guerre
un autre le concept développé par des
opérations intégrées dimensionnelle sert
de base pour poursuivre la construction
des forces armées simultanément et
éloignons les tentatives de renforcer le
régime d'occupation américains en irak
c'est comme ça que nous appelons le
déploiement des forces américains sur
les territoires de l'allemagne et de
l'italie
ses troupes au reste and you up à partir
de la conférence de yalta en 1945 il
s'agissait
il s'agit de l'occupation des pays de
l'ex cette occupation persistante
reprend 2,6 nous avons déjà à parler de
différents vecteurs de renforcement des
banques influencent 17-10 et indépendant
comme nous avons eu certains pays de
l'europe orientale se sont jetés dans
les bras de leurs salles nos alliés et
la pologne les pays baltes et l'ukraine
font vendre leur soupe on était à fond
vendre l'heure où ce faux dit la plus
féroce sur ce prétexte à l'épaule
le temps mais ce nouveau pays en une
base militaire est en train d'être
construite en pologne les pays bas
reçoivent de nombreux détachement des
chalets combat le crâne à appel elle est
rousse britannique à se tutoyer ce son
territoire
nous voyons comment les troupes des pays
qui ressassent eux commencent à
maîtriser les nouveaux théâtres de
guerre ferait de notre entière
s'inquiète quand ici on poursuit la
logique de l'occupation des états
européens par l'amérique et 11 fois la
cause de leur réaction à ce qui se passe
en biélorussie on croit que ces pays
n'ayant pas le droit
ce n était en vie cette indépendance à
notre pays en essayant de rendre la
bière et russian isolé en utilisant les
moyens de lanières hybride là les amours
les off le financier on utilise les
sanctions la concurrence et all déloyale
en refusant type d'influenceurs
incidents récents
leurs neuf de la compagnie renner a été
utilisée pour détruire notre système de
transport et nous en france et de plus
6e quand l'expansion et réalisé non
seulement dans les milieux classique et
globaliste l heure à sa vie
ensuite pour l'espace et ses tendances à
cet extrait baptisé l'espace coloniser
les milieux chez nouveau pour
s'approprier de nouveaux réchauffe
c'est comme ça que nous voyons arriver
des états unis déclaré l'espace milieu
des hostilités probable on trouve plus
de frontières étatiques et les
frontières d'état parce qu'est l'âme
sera déployé à une centaine de
kilomètres à partir de leurs cibles les
corporations transnationales et les
attaques et le contrôle ne se font ne
font pas limiter leurs intérêts par
l'espace à leur inspiration a dominé
dans l'espace cybernétique qui est de
plus en plus militarisé pour devenir
entraîneur et même de thé de
confrontation militaire
les technologies informatiques yeux
deviennent aux nouveaux types d'armes à
les réseaux sociaux deviennent angers
noyant efficace organiser des
révolutions de couleur les états
cherchent à contrôler facebook twiter
télégramme et d'autres régions ces
coopérations sont de plus en plus
menaçants à la
sécurité le souverain était là tu te des
états tiers
les pays sont de plus en plus nombreux
de profiter des états qu'elles
contrôlent pour promouvoir leurs
intérêts les autres ou qui est de plus
en plus de me lever
il s'agit des sociétés
chers collègues je viens d'énumérer les
problèmes les plus épineux auxquels sont
confrontés dans notre travail pour la
sécurité globale à la lutte de peau
notre futur notre stabilité à bat son
plein nous voyons que les pays garder
leur sérénité et leur indépendance
ce qui fait les états indépendants de se
faire une idée différence kloster et
différents blocs la public 2000 russie
est au centre du continent européen
bref à l'aller de confrontation des
intérêts géopolitiques de l'est et de
l'ouest du nord et du sud
ce qui ne laisse pas l'opportunité à
prendre notre distance de ces événements
le peuple ukrainien
le peuple a mis le russe a fait son
choix en louant le référent dans 1900 à
95 et nous poursuivrons notre travail à
renforcer la coopération au sens du
traité de la sécurité collective
d'autres trip est un signe à ce pays on
se rappellera pas contraires enfin
promouvoir aux en terre en ce qui
concerne les moments hors militaires de
l'opération non poursuivront la création
d'une politique mais certaines idées en
l'air dans laquelle nous proposons deux
reprises et à la notion d'adversaires et
sources say
menace qu'on soit dans le document final
il est évident que dans le contexte
actuel de la guerre qui brident il est
important de se poser non seulement à
des marionnettes et des maîtres de
marionnettes ici pour fuir le
développement des gains du franc fort
c'est bien les russes de trousses en
semblant d'être à la rue ce qu'on tend à
créer des centres commandes de formation
du personnel sur le territoire russe et
biélorusse aussi nous non content on
pouvait encore une fois le haut niveau
de cohésion des formations de troupes au
cours des exercices et stratégiques
occident de mévente et en sélection une
augmentation sans précédent à des
exercices et des pères des pays membres
de l'alliance au centre de nos
frontières
en général nous soyons que dans le monde
est multipolaire qui est en train d'être
d'être formé il est temps de voir lire
knees la confrontation
ces dernières années nous avons prouvé
notre horreur la biélorussie ne se
pliera pas il est temps de se mettre de
nous mettre à la table de négociation et
nous sommes prêts à négocier et apporter
notre contribution à prévenir toutes
sortes de conflits
minsk était ouvert pour toutes sortes de
la coopération qui visait la cvt et je
le remercie de votre attention
je veux remercier général crémines pour
votre intervention maintenant je tiens à
passer le perron le président du comité
international du coin rouge tim turner r
monsieur mavericks perec une grande
expérience de travers en tant qu'île
diplomates nos différentes fonctions au
département fédéral des affaires
étrangères suisse à partir de 2012 et
l'ex président
une organisation rude mais qui reste à
mon point de vue à la moins politisés
parmi les organisations internationales
et qui vient vise à assurer les changes
des otages les recherches tous les
prisonniers de guerre
cette collecte
c'est un grand plaisir un point
d'honneur de loterie c'est durant cette
9e conférence discussion vst3 l'ex
international et la sécurité
internationales que je m'adresse de la
défense dans la coopération entre la
russie et le comité international de
quoi ou gère en france et surtout dans
le contexte de la syrie du haut karabakh
et nous voyons le renforcement de notre
dialogue son physique qui nous avons aux
témoignages et dans d'autres capitales
du monde organisation saison dans 110
pays du monde nous réalisons notre
dialogue pour tout l'éventail des
questions commençant par la formation en
allant jusqu'à l'intégration
il est important que la stabilité le
début
160 s'organise nous avons construit le
site d un travail rationnel sur vie des
gens il est important aussi de
[Musique]
conditions de violence il faut respecter
le droit international faire respecter
le droit international pour assurer la
sécurité des civils et des équipes
facilité pour d'autres horizons terre et
notre volonté est basée à des principes
de la neutralité
notre objectif c'est avant tout la
confiance pour tous nos partenaires pour
s il est partie prenante de toutes
sortes d'hostilité et des confrontations
nous devons protéger leur dignité
nous sommes deux piscines et les
changements positifs sauf que des gens
les principes des conventions de genève
on reste en respectant toutes les
valeurs qui font la base de notre chez
nous voyons de multiples facteurs qui
font changer notre
les documents mais absente fait la
politique à sion d'armes nucléaires ce
contrebande otsuchi ligne antoine
l'odeur présente une menace pour le
futur de notre planète des situations un
peu partout au pays dans une guerre
entre 6h en temps on a eu 40 ans on est
présents en afghanistan celle que
parfois les sociétaires devenir
catastrophique
il faut faire notre mieux pour que notre
c'est ce que je savais qu'on structures
au niveau des tarifs actuels seulement
des conflits armés
mais les flux d'émigration des réfugiés
fuient les zones de concession
il faut faire quelque chose avec un ces
flux d'autres problèmes représentés par
des changements cosmétiques évidence est
aujourd'hui à ce que la dynamique du
monde comptent un peu ronde en
changement est ce qu'une housse et agir
ensemble pour trouver des solutions
quelque chose
des positifs et dépassent ceux qui
voient le monde change nous savons déjà
travaillé avec eux les différentes
ethnies nous sauverons a prêté cette
aide humanitaire nourriture notre system
sas en communauté mais du nouveau
problème c'est pas ça ce qui ne manque
pas nos foyers existants coins du monde
dans les zones rurales et à dans les
zones urbaines tout et on les voit de la
pauvreté de la pandémie d'autres
problèmes aujourd'hui personne ne doit
lutter seul il faut faire appel à des
forces armées c est à notre travail ce
qui est le point clé de notre succès
c'est en créant des alliances et des
unions que nous pouvons venir à bout de
notre activité on trouve des parties
prenantes qu'il sait déminer notre
activité et nous essayons de à réduire à
la menace des risques et à militaire et
protéger la population civile
nous sommes prêts à participer à un
dialogue qui commet avec les forces
armées de tous les états pour discuter
toutes sortes des questions
d'opportunité de notre agenda évidemment
il le faut des instruments appropriés
pour lutter contre les défis du démon
oui maintenant nous avons des
technologies de nouvelles technologies
nous voyons leur utilisation leur visage
les anges en supersonique l'espace
cybernétique tentait les gens sortent
ici elle mais il faut savoir les
véhicules il faut savoir les maîtriser
il s'agit en fait que au niveau
d'inventaire de 500 et me jeter
mauriange maintenant mais mon ce
contexte compliqué
de nombreuses attaques des pirates
informatiques des coupures d'électricité
à l'essai sensible avec les usages des
technologies de pointe
on a vu tout ce c'est baky et génère de
double menace et menace même l'existence
et des gens il faut poursuivre la
coopération les négociations il faut
coopérer la pandémie nous a faits divers
liés aux nouvelles couches et de ses
défis non seulement dans le domaine de
la santé publique se met dans la santé à
dos dans le domaine de la sécurité aussi
il faut aussi coopérer avec les oignons
du manteau de la paix et d'autres
services pour stabiliser la situation
post endémique et y compris dans le dos
mais qu'est ce qui te la santé publique
il s'agit de contrôler les frontières
contrôler les flux migratoires sans
faire appel à des candidatures de
l'autre et aux forces militaires nous
pouvons il faut tout faire ensemble pour
aboutir le faut présenter certaines et
de navigation pour l'assistance médicale
c'est ça ce qui fait entre autres le
comité national du croix rouge en
conférant à une façon active avec les
gouvernements avec les forces armées en
raison ça va être une sorte d'événement
et pour renforcer la coopération entre
ses danseurs certains facteurs que je
viens de mentionner qu'ils forment à
certains défis pour le secteur
humanitaire le comité international du
croix rouge et la wii ou encore opéré à
coup avec vous pour partager notre
expérience et combiner notre expérience
avec les avis des experts
toujours partagé joue durant notre
coopération de long terme que ces
persuadé que cette coopération pourrait
être on outil important pour la création
de ce monde fragile a pour l'heure pour
le rendre plus sûre sécurisée et sans
danger il faut le faire il faut le faire
en respectant nos consignes et nos
valeurs à nous tous les participants dit
que c'était coopération être la
législation internationale dans le
domaine de la santé publique doit être
respectée et le cycle pour garantir luz
âge légal à 2 des outils appropriés et
la participation légal et justifie dans
les zones des conflits
nous n'oublions pas notre volley à deux
formations en créant des programmes de
formation des doctrines pour aider nos
collègues et nos partenaires et notre
cause à vous nous n'oublions pas les
principes de transparence et de
coexistence pacifique ce qui nous permet
de dresser les lignes rouges à ne pas
franchir
chers collègues le comité international
du croix rouge c'est un partenaire
fiable qui reste toujours aidés de ceux
qui qui ont besoin de cette aide et
notre article est basé notre grande
expérience et ne sont prêts à la faire
partager notre ou coopérons avec la
police avec des forces armées il fut le
faisons dans plus d'une centaine pays
l'année passée
et par exemple nous avons coopéré avec
une cinquantaine des forces armées
nationales quantifions pays nous avons
réalisé ensemble de différents
événements nous avons à discuter les
questions de planification non seulement
dans le domaine de la santé publique et
mettant toute montée des deux événements
nous sommes prêts à faire partager
neutre et puis on se non seulement dans
le domaine médical ou du droit
humanitaire nous sommes prêts à coopérer
avec la police et d'autres regardent
maintien de l'ordre de questions
pratiques et qui trouve de plus en plus
d'importance
vous pouvez le trouver dans le peu de
notre dos comme tant d'autres documents
dans notre document méthodologique qui
ne l'oublions pas les nouvelles
technologies
nos séminaires de formation fait appel à
des outils à thomas la réalité augmentée
ou virtuels masque feng nous permet de
faire partager notre expérience nous
avons déjà une en bon dialogue
substantiel et pour nourrir ce travail
il faut poursuivre notre coopération en
respect des règles et des principes et
déshonneur et maintenant à cette 9e
conférence demo sur la sécurité
discussion et c'est à des crampes la
science que j'attends les interventions
d'autres panélistes pourront se voir on
conclut c'est reprendre votre expérience
je vous remercie de votre attention
cher monsieur nous vous remercions pour
votre intervention concernant les
activités les compétences du comité
international de la croix rouge
maintenant la parole est donnée à
l'adjoint au chef de l'état major
général le général de brigade du cours
des gardes de la révolution
monsieur rabbani c'est un commandant
militaire est très expérimenté vraiment
un professionnel de très haut niveau au
nom d'allah le clément le miséricordieux
mesdames et messieurs je suis ravi je
vous remercie de la possibilité de me
retrouver dans un pays amical pour
intervenir lors de la 9ème confiance de
moscou sur la sécurité internationale et
concernant la proche de l'iran face aux
changements régionaux et globaux pour
cette raison je considère nécessaire de
remercier les organisateurs de ce forum
au cours de ces dernières décennies des
événements inattendus ont eu lieu dont
chacun a eu ses propres conséquences
dont la victoire de la révolution
islamique en iran les événements dans la
région de l'asie occidentale et
lâchement de la guerre froide ont fait
sortir le monde dieu l'état bipolaire et
les états unis de l'amérique ont
considéré qu'ils ont atteint
leder chip est indiscutable mais quand
même
le système du multilatéralisme a eu lieu
et s'est établi dans le monde entier et
en plus nous avons vu des changements
qui ont été suscités par le vigneron et
des peuples ces derniers à venir en asie
occidentale et en amérique du nord mais
malheureusement à cause de la gérance
des états unis et du monde de palestine
ses conséquences
une car était imprévisible et qui ont
fait la promotion du thé russe intériste
dans le monde entier
chers amis mesdames et messieurs c'est
gouvernement hégémonie en utilisant les
outils des sanctions et des menaces en
imposant leur volonté les deux
détonations l'occupation ont devenus les
racines des conséquences comme la
discrimination de genre de race la
tyrannie est l'extrémisme et le
terrorisme est d'ethnie et la concussion
et le croque monde des sept artistes
étant des produits de perception
mercantile et commercialisation de la
sécurité et ces dernières années par des
pauvres a indiqué et grâce à la
mobilisation et la détermination de ses
forces armées du gouvernement et du
peuple de la syrie de l'irak et surtout
au soutien de
les république islamique d'iran de la
fédération de russie
cette approche dangereuse échoué au
niveau régional et national et les
efforts des états unis visant à
contrôler ces événements et faire
survivre le dev sur le champ de combat y
pour deux trois décennies n'ont pas eu
de résultats il y a été déclaré comme
lâchement de dèche mais finalement les
facteurs de d'apparitions et de
manifestations de cette perception et de
raisonnement extrémistes et terroristes
sont toujours en vigueur etc plusieurs
facteurs
toujours efficace surtout pour saper la
sécurité la stabilité créé des obstacles
pour resterez l'insécurité
l'instauration de la paix aujourd'hui
allez pouvoir est transnational comme
les pouvoirs terroristes du commandement
central de des états unis et cinq hommes
dont l ena portel sont des gens au civil
ils doivent quitter les régions de
l'asie occidentale pour assurer et la
possibilité dépit de ce triste jour il
faire son propre choix et assurer la
sécurité
mesdames et messieurs finalement nous
sommes tellement et des changements de
la puissance géopolitique dans le
système international et de la
transition de la
force et de la puissance globale à
partie de l'hémisphère occidental vers
l'hémisphère oriental
évidemment ces changements et transition
de la corse fait face à l'opposition de
la part des pouvoirs traditionnels
ici la compréhension de la sécurité par
les joueurs
la trouve pas sa bonne compréhension
fondée sur l'air elle était elle est
faite
l'espoir pour la paix le ca vian le
monde ne va sera pas fructueux et
finalement nous devons apporter la
tension changement des attentes des
peuples
concernant la vie dans ce monde la
sécurité individuelle ne peut être plus
le garant de la prospérité pour les
états parce que dans les états
comptables pour elle la sécurité
collective et l'attention à ce fait a
acquis dans l'opinion publique plus
d'importance par rapport la sécurité
individuelle et pendant les crises de la
pandémie
il n'est plus possible de gérer les
crises par voie traditionnelle la guerre
nucléaire a eu et représentait une
grande peur pendant le xxème siècle mais
aujourd'hui un envoyons les nouvelles
missions de défense qui ont été écrits
pour faire face à ces menaces
mais nous devons faire face aux
nouvelles menaces surtout à partir de la
cellule où nous jouerons pas c'est que
nous vivons le temps de la révolution de
changement surtout dans les supers
espace ces changements a créé une
nouvelle expérience de vie pour
l'humanité ou une action dans les
cyberespaces peu le transfert
transformer en réaction globale à dans
le monde derrière
sur ce fait les homo ni deux les
cyberespaces et la transformation des
domaines vitaux a rendu le cyber-espace
qu'en réalité parallèle de l'humanité
évidemment cette menace comme elles
restent anonymes et jour un impact
surprenant a créé un phénomène comme qui
s'appelle la prolifération de la force
parce qu'elle a résulté un apparition de
nouveaux jeux comme de nouveaux
groupements et personne dans l'équation
globale des forces donc et ce phénomène
a un impact sur la sécurité nationales
des deux pays du point de vue de la
sécurité de caractère centric et de
l'état de l'aspect géographique de la
menace de la fragilité de la fragilité
mesdames et messieurs la république
islamique et dire on joue pour les
meilleures relations avec tous les pays
du monde et surtout en jouant son rôle
dans la politique extérieure parce que
c'est vraiment important et surtout aux
dons y manifester dans la résolution des
crises régionales
chers collègues aujourd'hui compte tenu
des changements de très grande vitesse
dans le monde et surtout la conjugaison
des menaces indiqué et devaient le
caractère il faut que les états
indépendants par l'intermédiaire de leur
contribution à la stabilité régionale
dans le monde -et je veux souligner que
notre et république islamique vieillit
et dire on est toujours prêt à coopérer
avec les pires pour cette raison nous
devrions partager avec vous les proprios
suivante la première le changement de la
compréhension mercanti de la sécurité sa
commercialisation la deuxième la mise en
place de la confiance sur la base du
mode de la sécurité unique dans le cadre
du respect mutuel
loeb consécutive troisième à la
consultation de la friture à peu créé et
développé à l'intérieur les réseaux et
intérieur de la sécurité surtout pour
soutenir ceux qui assurent la sécurité
et la paix merci beaucoup de votre
compréhension et de votre patience
merci beaucoup pour votre position
exprimée concernant la sécurité
régionale et globale exprimer maintenant
l'international monsieur hamid karzaï
qui toujours avec nous par
visioconférence depuis kaboul hamid
karzaï est qui est un homme politique
très expérimenté qui a occupé plusieurs
fois le leader de la république ait pas
de l'afghanistan est depuis 2004
il gère le fonds de la fondation d'amy
cars et pour promouvoir les générations
de la jeunesse et il participe en
permanence au forum de moscow c'est à
vous la parole merci beaucoup
cher monsieur hamid karzaï mes chers
collègues merci beaucoup de cette
possibilité car monsieur amis nerfs
mesdames et messieurs je suis ravi de
cette possibilité d'intervenir devant
vous mais évidemment je serais beaucoup
plus heureux si je pouvais assister avec
vous à cette conférence à moscou parce
qu'avant j'étais capable de venir
personnellement mais malheureusement la
situation actuelle me faire rester où je
suis et utiliser ce format de
visioconférence tout ça vivons dans un
nouveau ton ans dans une nouvelle ère et
nous voyons l'apparition du nouvel ordre
mondial
un même temps nous voyons la nécessité
de l'apparition de nouvelles règles pour
que nous puissions gérer mieux ce nouvel
landre mondiale
il existe des problèmes mais quand même
il existe de nouvelles opportunités
nouvelles possibilités et à mon avis
nous considérons des aspects différents
et est la rencontre entre le président
russe et son homologue américain sert
d'un signe de l'espoir que les problème
puisse être résolu et les oppositions et
les divergences puisse être surmontés
surtout la compétition continue la
rivalité entre différents pays sert
d'une source de la preuve du patient et
nos problèmes et non des filles sont
universelles elles sont toujours
d'actualité pour nous tous nous devons
faire face tous ensemble et je peux y
citer entre autres les changements
climatiques les problèmes d'alimentation
des engrais la cybersécurité à le
terrorisme à la migration
et bien sûr ce qui est extrêmement
important les armes de d'importance
stratégique mais quand même je ne peux
que c'est c'est pas ceux qui sinon je
vais continuer à citer sa paume ces
problèmes parce qu'ils sont mondiaux la
coopération aussi bien que le
partenariat surtout entre les pouvoirs
et les puissances mondiales vont assurer
la stabilité et l'efficacité de l'ordre
du monde
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs l'eurasie l'asie
de l'est l'asie de l'ouest représente un
seul classe terre unique et cette région
actuellement
sert de jalons et surtout d'une racine
et dieu source la plus importante du
développement ultérieur surtout dons au
centre
surtout dans le contexte de l'eurasie de
la chine et de sa région un pays comme
afghanistan je roule important parce que
l'afghanistan a des frontières avec la
chine a comme avec d'autres pays et nous
avons des relations étroites avec
différents pays y compris la russie et
monsieur capeline qui s'appelle la
revanche de la géographie a décrit
l'afghanistan comme un pays qui se
trouve dans un endroit stratégique et
pan dont les habitants de l'afghanistan
a aussi des conséquences pour nous et
surtout pour notre région
dans l'ensemble il ya plusieurs
décennies les grands philosophes à la
merde barre dans ce grand poème est très
connu à parler de l'afghanistan il a
écrit et l'autre jour
l'asie est lié avec l'eau et les argiles
et surtout dans ce corps de l'eau de
l'argile l'afghanistan séjour le rôle du
coeur et la prospérité le bien-être de
l'afghanistan est directement lié avec
ceux des billets de la vie'' elle les
problèmes avec ce choeur avec cet organe
du corps réside un problème pour l'asie
et dans ce contexte mesdames et
messieurs nous a mis une attaque contre
une école organisé par des sèche qui a
engagé sa responsabilité est revendiqué
sa responsabilité plus de 80 écolière de
l'afghanistan sont mortes pendant cette
attaque ne connaissons pas pourquoi le
déchet ses représentants puis
c'est et doit venir en afghanistan pour
tuer une petite jeune fille qu'elle a
lyon entre eux avant avec nos écoles il
est évident que dans ce cas c'est le
peuple afghan qui souffrent à cause de
ces phénomènes le plus grande échelle
qui ne sont pas directement liées avec
nous et surtout ses souffrances et un
des exemples mais quand même et qui joue
un jeune star qui m'a fait faire prendre
la parole lors de cette conférence en
parlant de la stabilité stratégique de
cette région
j'ai déjà visité moscou j'ai déjà
assisté ou plusieurs conférences
consacrées aux problèmes de l'extrémisme
et du terrorisme surtout de leur impact
sur la région dans l'ensemble mais quand
même aujourd'hui je veux m'adresser
surtout représentants des plus grandes
puissances et je vais vous demander
d'essayer d'assurer la stabilité parce
que sinon nous voyons les problèmes et
les résultats et les conséquences
directes et indirectes dans cette région
comme dans notre pays parce que nous
subissons les conséquences de ces
problèmes je vais pas parler des raisons
être des racines parce que nous avons
déjà abordé ce sujet par le passé
plusieurs fois j'aime pas approfondir
dans ce sujet les etats unis sont venus
au début des années 2000 est sur le
territoire dans notre pays
et cette action ont été chaleureusement
accueillis par d'autres pays et nous
vous voyez des représentants de nos
voisins lors de cette conférence de
moscou qui puisse le confirmer mais
quand même ces transformations aurait dû
provoquer des résultats des conséquences
de quelque nature à l'afghanistan
et quand nous avons vu pendant les jours
précédents nous voyons l'opposé les
conflits se sont aggravées la sécurité
s'est aggravée et surtout encore une
fois
l'afghanistan fait face au futur ambiguë
qu'est ce que cela veut dire
cela veut dire que les gens doivent
résoudre ces problèmes en commun parce
que nous savons très bien que tout seul
nous n'allons pas remporté la victoire
surtout lors de cette crise activée
mesdames et messieurs aujourd'hui c'est
un bon jour pour que notre grande région
et les états voisins aussi bien que des
grandes puissances mondiales puisse
commencer à jouer un rôle plus juste et
véritable pour assurer la sécurité de
l'afghanistan pour assurer sa prospérité
et j'aimerais rappeler qu'il ya trois
jours là les etats unis ont commencé le
processus de pacification en afghanistan
qui a été chaleureusement soutenu par la
population de l'afghanistan pas c'est
que nos citoyens veulent vivre dans un
monde et pendant le temps de paix
évidemment les gens avaient l'espoir que
les transformations se passe très vite
mais quand même et ses activités de
pacification dur pendant trois ans et
quand même la situation s'aggrave nous
voyons de plus en plus de
moore et la crise en afghanistan compte
dans des pays voisins s'aggrave et nous
croyons que la participation de la
russie de la chine à ce processus sera
aussi bien que du pakistan puisse faire
une grande contribution afin d'assurer à
la paix en afghanistan et surtout pour
ceux que ce puisse avoir des résultats
concrets nous espérons que l'iran adhère
à ce processus hobby si bien que l'inde
et la turquie
nous espérons qu'ils vont participer à
ce processus passé qu eux
à leur tour ils ont une influence dans
cette région est depuis le novembre 2018
la russie jusqu'à présent et surtout en
mars dernier nous avons vu les derniers
rencontres de haut niveau entre
l'afghanistan la russie parce qu'avant
depuis mars 2018
nous avons vu un dialogue permanent ça
veut dire des limites depuis 2018 nous
avons l'intensification du dialogue
entre la russie l'afghanistan et pour ce
fait nous rions remercié la russie pour
sa participation à ce dialogue surtout
pour son soutien à la partie afghanistan
et à libon pour retrouver un tel que
compromis nous remercions la russie pour
ses efforts qui visent à initier
les négociations pourraient assurer la
paix dans cette région et surtout comme
j'ai déjà dit en mars dernier nous avons
vu une grande rencontre à moscou avec
les participations des états unis du
pakistan de la turquie et les
représentants des deux parties du
pakistan ont été invités pour participer
à cette rencontre à moscou en mars
dernier et finalement nous avons tiré
les conclusions que pour notre tous à
l'objectif principal c'est la paix dans
la région et l'aghanistan participera
toujours à ce sujet nous espérons que
toutes les régions nous c'est tiéné dans
ce moment vers la paix mesdames et
messieurs la paix en afghanistan et la
stabilité en afghanistan
nous croyons que ces deux notions sont
liées entre elles et nous pensons que la
stabilité en afghanistan est lié avec sl
dans la région dans l'ensemble et si
l'afghanistan est un prospérité se sera
paré pour toute la région dans son
ensemble
comme je viens de dire l'afghanistan
c'est le centre de la région
surtout pour cette raison pour rester en
prospérité
il faut et pour assurer la prospérité et
le bien-être de la région il faut
assurer celle de l'afghanistan en tant
que le coeur de cette région et surtout
au cours de ce processus
seul vers la paix il faut que les
organisations internationales aussi bien
que d'autres pays participent
parce que ça nous permettra d'assurer la
meilleure sécurité la prospérité
d'ensemble dans cette région c'est ce
que notre nation veut qu'ils souffrent
pendant plusieurs décennies
et qui s'offre pas à cause de son mes
propres erreurs nous voulons que nos
espoirs deviennent les réalités parce
que c'est andy main basique et nous
aspirons et moi car c'est mon j'espère
que vous tous allés participer à ce
processus
et je veux rajouter que la
responsabilité des citoyens de
l'afghanistan être très bien comprise
par le peuple de l'afghanistan parce que
nous voulons avoir une position sur ne
voulons pas être dépendant dans quelques
pays tout seul nous voulons jouer un
rôle de garant de la stabilité de la
région et nous voulons avoir de bonnes
relations avec la communauté
internationale et je vous rassure que
tout une au citoyen le soutiennent merci
beaucoup de votre attention je vous
remercie monsieur 15 hae pour votre
vision des défis et des menaces à
l'échelle globale et régionale
sait-il que l'humanité doit utiliser
pour un autre fait des essais menace
chez un ami là on a terminé notre
première session plénière en je remercie
tous les participants et on remercie
particulièrement les panélistes mé ment
on va faire une pause d'une trentaine de
minutes à suite de quoi vous êtes
attendus à la deuxième session plénière
de la conférence qui sera consacrée aux
questions de la sécurité dans la région
d'asie et du pacifique
[Musique]